.
What we will do in this show is, through a set of
Examples, recognition
The coordinate system x, y
First, take a look at some of the points
Actually set and find its coordinates
Then we'll look at some coordinates and find
Where are these points located?
Then we will solve another issue
If let's find what they are
Coordinates of these points?
Here we have this point A
You can see it here
You can turn it down
Which intersection x axis?
x = 5
It's a 5 point, and y will equal 6
5.6
Now this point B here, what is the x-coordinate?
It's 5 to the left
5 to the left of the x axis
This is -5
The x-coordinate is -5
The y coordinate is, if we move straight to the right
We will reach y = 5
y = 5
Let's change the colors
C
I think you absorbed it
Let's start first with Y. The y coordinate is 3
As you see here
Then the x-coordinate is -2
We always put x coordinates first. thats it
The agreement we use
In D, the x-coordinate is -2
As you see here
The y-coordinate is -2 as well
Let me use another color
E, let's find the coordinate y
We will find him first, but he will
You should always write it second
He-4
As you can see here, y coordinate
The x is 3
Finally, F
The x coordinate is 2
The y-factor is -6
I hope that this is your idea about finding
Coordinates
Now let's go in the other direction
Let's start with coordinates and find where those fall
Points
If we have the first
I will write it with a small symbol between the brackets until we divide it
About this A
It is located at 4.2, ie x = 4
And y = 2
If x = 4 and y = 2
This is the point here
Let us solve the following
Let me use a color that is easy for you to read
b
x = -3
y = 5.5
We move all this distance to 5.5
This is the point (b)
Then c, which is 4, -4, ie x = 4
And y = -4
Here
Then the last point
I will write it in orange
d, which is x = -2, and y = -3
x = -2, and y = -3
Here
These are (d)
You can go in the other direction
It can say, that y = -3
And x = -2
Go to the left and down
Or you can go to the peppers and to the left
And continue to go until you reach the same point
I hope this gave you a good grasp of how to find
Coordinates
Or if given coordinates, how to find
Where coordinates x, y
Now let's solve issues that contain more
As follows, if we have 3 points are considered three heads
For box A, B, C, D
Then set them on the graph
Then select the coordinates of the fourth point
Which is D
Well, let's set them on the chart. as such
It is required of us
this is good
This will be the y axis
This is the y axis
Vertical axis
This will be the x axis
X axis
Let me put some - let me see her
x This is equal to 1, 2, 3, 4
x This is equal to -1, -2, -3
And y = 1, 2, 3, 4
y equals -1, -2, -3
I can write that y = 4
And y are equal to -4, and x = 4
x = -4
And let's see
Let us identify these points
We first have point A and are equal to -4,
We go on x to -4
Then y = -4
The Fancy 4 is down here
This is point A
-4, -4
So that the appointment is familiar to you
If you have not seen it before, that's where
Some people call these parts of the coordinate system
This is called the first quarter
This is called the second quarter
This is called the third quarter
This is called the fourth quarter
These Roman numerals I, II, III and
IV, if this point falls in the third quarter
When we look at all this here, these points
Located in the fourth quarter
This is in the third quarter, the second, the first. it's a
Something interesting to know
Sometimes someone asks you, what quarter
Where is this point located?
You'll say, well, I'll see
If both are negative, they will be in
Third quarter
If y is negative, x is positive
Will be in the fourth quarter
If both are positive, they will be in the first quarter. If y
Positive, but negative x, will be in the second quarter
And we'll talk a little about it when
We identify these points
Point B, x is positive
Namely 1, 2, 3
And y = -4
We put it here in this quarter
This point B
Namely, 3, -4
We can actually see the rectangle button which
They talk about him, here
Notice, both have the same y value
Both are located at the same level below the x axis
What is the next point?
Point C is 3.3
3.3
Located in the first quarter
Their coordinates are positive
3.3
Both x and y are positive
They observed, it is vertical as B
It has the same value of x
Both have an x ​​value of 3
It's located here
above it
Now we have to find the last point
Well, the point should be the same
Straightness like this is the point
Will be on the same straightness of these
Point, meaning it must have the same value as x
this point
Its x value is -4
Then they are on the same row
this point
Will be on the same
Describe this point
It must have the same y value as the same
Height above the x-axis
Must be 3
This is point D
They noted it was located at -4, above A
And y = 3
To the left of point C
We're done
.